I like to sit not down front cuz I don't
want to look like this I like kind of
the middle back my go-to movie snack is
Eminem's with popcorn the sweet and
salty that sticks around on your behind
but it's worth it it's so good hello
gorgeous
let's check out how you look today short
and stubby and my gosh couldn't look
better I love raising it and I love pop
I would say a little sno-caps
I like smoke that's a lot Reese's Pieces
I like to sit all the way in the back
and like throw gummy bears at the
theater I know and see which one sticks
and sometimes I liked wigglers and
sometimes I like a red bye
yeah I go through seasons this is the
Institute of perfection and perfect
dolls have perfect eyesight oh I like to
sit kind of in the middle to the right I
like to be close enough that I can get
out if I have to go to the restroom or
pick up more popcorn but I also like to
be kind of letting the center so get the
sound the right way I must be like in
the middle of the theater cannot be too
close cannot be too far back this is
I'll right there if his 15 seats put me
in at least the 7/8 the popcorn it's not
just limited to movies though it's sort
of one of my favorite snacks in the
world I like it just normal no butter or
no like just just a normal popcorn it's
got to be hot that's the main thing
every breakdown
sneak your foodie and if you like
[Music]